the opioid crisis is not only dangerous
for those addicted to the drugs but also
for first responders we told you
yesterday about an Ohio police officer
who survived an accidental overdose from
Street fentanyl after a drug bust the
DEA says it is 40 to 50 times more
powerful than Street heroin Jim Axelrod
spoke with that officer and he's in East
Liverpool Ohio where this all happened
Jim good morning good morning officer
Chris green of the East Liverpool Police
Department came in contact with fentanyl
while helping to arrest a couple of drug
suspects during a traffic stop anyone
who wants to know just how powerful and
deadly fentanyl is should hear his story
right about here start to feel a little
funny yeah as I walked through the door
I was almost pulled back by an alert
colleague another officer what's this
white powder and that's when I reach
back accidentally came in contact you're
standing roughly right here yeah just a
few hours earlier officer Chris Green
was helping arrest two men on alleged
drug charges who were in this car you
can see the white powder on the floor
officer green doesn't know how some of
that powder got on his sweatshirt but
when it ended up on his fingertips
that's all it took I fall backwards I'm
trying to trying to hold on to anything
I can grasp
luckily EMTs were already at the police
station officer green was given one dose
of the opioid antidote naloxone and then
rushed to the hospital where he received
three more doses so a total of four
doses of narcan yes for simply touching
that and or inhaling am I being a little
overdramatic here to say you could have
died I don't think so
Chris's fiancee Stacey Burch knows he
has a dangerous job but worried more
about bullets than drugs did you ever
think he did encounter something like
this absolutely
my worst fear is like getting shot but
fentanyl especially in powder form is so
dangerous and now spreading across the
country so fast that they'll now is
being sold but the DEA made a video
recording police and emergency
responders of the risks as long as this
stuff is on the street our men and women
our first responders are going to be
bumping into it and it's extraordinarily
dangerous for them when you hear about
these stories you think that's selling
on TV it's not gonna happen to me that's
not gonna happen to me this drug doesn't
care who he kills no conscious no
conscious officer Green says the
suspects admitted to him that the white
powder was fentanyl now this happened on
a Friday officer Green was scheduled to
be off Saturday Sunday and Monday back
to work Tuesday so Galle this harrowing
story an officer green didn't miss a
single day of work Wow
go officer green but another layer to
the opioid crisis thank you very much